[Música]
eu estou aqui hoje para falar de um
assunto bastante simples que seu negócio
de passar os slides mas já está chegando
a beleza é um assunto muito simples que
eu tenho certeza que a maioria de vocês
já ouviu falar em algum momento talvez
por algum motivo não tenha colocado em
prática e talvez não tenha a noção da
dimensão do impacto desse assunto talvez
é um assunto que é muito caro pra mim é
muito importante que é um pedido
bastante direto e objetivo também
esse assunto é separe seu lixo
eu cheguei nesse assunto é quando eu
ainda estava na faculdade em 2008 mas o
velho estudava ciências sociais em
araraquara da unesp e tava perdido entre
teorias de como mudar o mundo lendo
livros e mais livros e com vontade de
colocar a mão na massa de fazer algo
concreto para mudar as coisas e de
repente eu vi que meus amigos estavam
por aí fazendo horta construindo casa
com terra captando água de chuva e
descobri que tudo isso tinha um nome e
que se chamava permacultura é um outro
jeito de viver a vida ou cultura da
permanência o jeito mais sustentável
um jeito mais ético de viver a vida que
engloba muitos elementos e que traz uma
ferramenta de design planejamento de
espaços humanos sustentáveis a partir de
uma série de princípios e de uma ética
muito rudimentar baseado em três pilares
o cuidado com a terra o cuidado com as
pessoas ea partir da junção dos
excedentes
eu comecei a me apaixonar por tudo isso
este jeito de viver de fazer as coisas
de colocar a mão na massa e fiz aquilo
que pra mim é o mais interessante pra
aprender algo de fato eu comecei a
viajar e aí eu viajei uma boa parte do
brasil e da américa latina por aí de
carona pedindo esticando dentro da pista
dormindo em posto de gasolina dormindo
na rua
contando com a solidariedade das pessoas
pedindo comida trocando o trabalho por
estadia e alimentação e cada lugar que
eu ia buscando esses centros de
permacultura eu fazia uma coisa essa
foto numa fazenda perto de brasília onde
gente bill construiu um centro de
meditação com uma técnica chama
superadobe que basicamente é uma técnica
com sacos e terra e em cada lugar a
gente fazer uma coisa diferente
trabalhávamos com agrofloresta
reflorestamento agricultura de
diferentes formas de criação e depois de
um tempinho viajando aí voltei para
minha cidade natal para são carlos e
decidir realizar um processo aqui em
2012 a gente fundou um grupo chamado
associação veracidade para difundir a
permacultura para falar de tudo isso na
cidade de são carlos e com muita gente
não foi pouca gente não em que começou
um processo de aplicar isso na prática e
começamos pela nossa casa então lá na
nossa casa que é a sede da ong onde a
gente mora numa comunidade com algumas
pessoas
a gente tem um pouco de tudo isso
aplicado temos a nossa horta orgânica
que não usa nenhum tipo de veneno insumo
químico esta horta irrigada com água de
chuva quente capita armazená lá mesmo
temos os minhocários que há uma
alternativa para a gestão de resíduos em
pequenos espaços
o banheiro seco que não usa água potável
tratada para transportar nossos
excrementos agente composta lá mesmo de
maneira segura os nossos próprios
resíduos
o forno solar para cozinhar usando o sol
forno à lenha que gera cinza que é boa
para a agricultura os painéis
fotovoltaicos para geração de energia
elétrica água e floresta que o modelo de
produção agrícola que se espelha nas
florestas para produzir comida e que
prova que é possível produzir comida pra
todo mundo sem destruir a biodiversidade
muito pelo contrário criando vida no
solo no ar na água em todas as suas
formas
a gente também faz a compostagem lá que
a reciclagem dos resíduos orgânicos
ao invés de jogar lixo no aterro
sanitário temos nossas galinhas que não
são umas são 30
temos várias galinhas na felizes que
ficam soltas né
a gente começou os ovos dela e tudo isso
em uma casa
o espaço urbano de mil metros aqui
próximo na vila prado quem quiser lá
visitá convidado a gente recebe grupos e
escolas para conhecer um pouco do seu
jeito de viver a vida e eu fui me
aprofundando nisso e isso virou também o
meu projeto de pesquisa de mestrado
eu decidi viajar de novo eu gosto de
viajar e visitar os grupos do brasil que
trabalham com isso e entender quem eles
são e onde estão o que querem e fiz meu
mestrado na usp em piracicaba esalq ea
partir disso tudo eu cheguei nessa
questão que pra mim é tão importante que
a questão dos resíduos que é um dos
aspectos que a permacultura também fala
que é algo que diz respeito a todo mundo
todo mundo gera resíduo em uma
circunstância ou outra em maior ou menor
proporção ea maneira como encara isso
pra mim é muito interessante então gosto
muito de uma frase é que eu uso bastante
pra pensar isso que é a seguinte
lixo é uma questão de contexto nada é
lixo
as coisas estão lixo quando elas são
inúteis para a gente quando ela vai para
um outro lugar ela passa a ser útil para
a gente ela deixa de ser lixo ela perde
essa condição de lixo e ela passa a ser
útil íntimo da nossa perspectiva e se
você olha de perto isso quem chama de
lixo nessa categoria que engloba tantas
coisas a gente vai ver que tem muita
coisa diferente dentro desse lixo só
para se ter uma idéia da composição da
renda domiciliar no brasil
dividido em três grandes categorias para
facilitar aqui
mais da metade desses resíduos são
resíduos orgânicos 52% cascas folhas
frutas etc 32% são materiais recicláveis
não é de fácil é reutilização nesse
sentido da reciclagem papel papelão
metal e certa e 16% são chamados
rejeitos aqueles que a gente ainda não
sabe muito bem como reciclar o que não
dá pra compostar bom ainda têm noção dos
números nem quantidades agora cada
brasileiro e brasileira produz mais ou
menos um quilo de lixo por dia e em
outros lugares do mundo a gente tem
outros padrões que dá nota também o
padrão de consumo dois quilos por
habitante dia nos estados unidos três
quilos na média europeia
é lixo ou resíduos pra caramba a gente
tem uma dimensão de nove números né
só que no brasil são 75 milhões de
toneladas de lixo todos os anos né 200
mil toneladas por dia é muita coisa e
que a gente vai fazer com isso
ainda mais se a gente pensa que do ponto
de vista do planeta onde vive no planeta
finito
tudo vem de algum lugar e vai para algum
lugar essa pressão jogar fora e já
explicita uma mentalidade de jogar fora
de onde pode vir do planeta isso não
existe não existe jogar fora
nesse caso que a gente faz então com
isso qualquer brilhante solução para
lidar com a quantidade imensa de
resíduos que a gente produz bom
pasmem a grande solução vendida por aí
são os chamados aterros sanitários né o
que são os aterros
eles são basicamente buracos cavados no
solo que você impermeabiliza com alguns
controles ambientais para enterrar esse
resíduo quando esse buraco está cheio
sendo um pouquinho mais procura um outro
lugar
cavou o buraco e assim por diante não me
parece algo muito sustentável pensando
nessa finitude do planeta né
além de outros problemas que a gente vai
ver um deles é a questão da parte
líquida dos resíduos quando esses
resíduos vão todos misturados por um
aterro sanitário aqueles materiais
orgânicos que são a maioria eles falta
um líquido em contato com os outros
materiais esse líquido que é uma coisa
maravilhosa para a agricultura é uma
sopa de nutrientes para as plantas se
tornar algo tóxico por isso tem que
penalizar o solo para não contaminar a
água etc e tal
eu quero uma solução se torna um
problema aí eu pergunto pra vocês né tá
realmente parece que não funciona
mas por que será que as coisas
funcionando do jeito que será que é
assim a gente para pensar tem sempre
alguém está ganhando dinheiro com as
coisas como elas são e aí se alguém
achar que foi um equívoco por acaso do
tipo nossa por deu errado não é por
acaso tá viajando na verdade tem gente
que gosta muito desse modelo porque
ganha muito dinheiro com isso na
especial as grandes empresas do ramo
e também porque não há outro assunto
espinhoso os nossos ilustres políticos
eleitos que não raro têm relações
umbilicais com as empresas do setor que
têm suas campanhas financiadas nas
próximas eleições por essas mesmas
empresas
aquele velho esquema que se conhecem do
jeitinho brasileiro
uma mão lava a outra uma licitação
fraudada aqui e acolá um assunto muito
complexo e tem que ser debatido
só em são carlos são 20 milhões de reais
todos os anos que vão para uma empresa
que realiza o serviço sem transparência
de uma maneira insustentável
agora se essa não é a melhor solução que
a gente pode fazer então para mudar as
coisas de fato estou trazendo pra vocês
aqui hoje eu disse quero uma solução
bastante simples é tal separação de
resíduos na fonte porque estou falando
isso e que significa fonte a fonte a
nossa onde resida gerado lá em casa
então a nossa proposta para facilitar
esse processo que muitas vezes se
confunde com metodologias mais
complicadas né
esquece essas latinha colorida que nem
eu sei para que serve a todos isso aí
vamos nos concentrar uma solução mais
simples em três categorias básicas foram
aquelas que eu apresentei a ele pra
vocês que já vai ajudar em muito pra
pensar um projeto de gestão integrada
dos resíduos porque esses resíduos todos
misturados são inúteis separados a gente
pode dar um encaminhamento correto para
cada um deles
quem tiver em casa ao invés de um
baldinho um saquinho de lixo mais três
que nenhum ato muito transformador a
gente consegue contribuir de uma forma
bastante importante para possibilitar os
processos que aproveitam esses quesitos
e lá em casa a gente tem essas três
baldes
a gente tem um balde lá tem até mais
porque tem as galinhas que comem as
minhocas
mais uma residência comum poderia ter
três baldes apenas um produto orgânico
sun para os recicláveis e um para os
rejeitos muito simples muito fácil se a
gente fizer isso 84 por cento dos
resíduos gerados nas casas do brasil
poderiam ser reaproveitados de alguma
forma seja através da compostagem da
reciclagem
ao invés de destinados para um aterro
sanitário de maneira inútil
insustentável bom que a gente poderia
fazer o sexto
chávez tem mais de 1500 cooperativas de
catadores e catadoras de materiais
recicláveis no brasil que vivem nela
recolhendo vendendo esses resíduos que
geram emprego renda e cidadania que
poderia juntar o material para dar para
uma cooperativa dessas ou para algum
catador o catador independente enfim
qualquer alternativa que não o aterro
aqui em são carlos mesmo nós temos uma
cooperativa lutadora de guerreiros e
guerreiras
a cooper vida que gera mais de 70 postos
de trabalho directos
apesar de todo o boicote do poder
público que tem outros interesses que
não o bem comum eles estão resistindo
trabalhando gerando emprego renda e
cidadania através daquilo que a gente
descarta os orgânicos
a gente pode fazer compostagem tem
várias formas de compostar tem
compostagem maior escala menor escala em
casa
não vou citar todos aqui senão o tempo
não vai dar mas basicamente é pegar
estas cascas de frutas e folhas que
sobram misturar com materiais secos e
transformar isso em adubo para a
agricultura
né ii traz uma série de benefícios né
além de desviar seus resíduos do aterro
sanitário como ele falou
indo pro utilidade né ele gera o
composto para agricultura orgânica ou
seja a nossa agricultura convencional é
baseada em insumos externos cepisa de
cada vez mais fertilizantes em geral são
fertilizantes químicos para aquele solo
seja capaz de produzir e aquela coisa
vem de algum lugar e vai para algum
lugar
esse fertilizante vai pro rio vai pro
solo produz alimentos envenenados
contaminados está propondo uma prática
que além de tirar resíduos do aterro
aumentando em seis vezes a vida útil dos
aterros já era composto por uma
agricultura de base ecológica gera
comida saudável gera pessoas saudáveis
economizar recursos públicos como a
gente já viu é algo racional é algo
inteligente de ser feito e promove a
educação ambiental pelo contato das
pessoas com uma outra forma de lidar e
de ver os seus resíduos e
fundamentalmente criando novos hábitos é
eu desde pequeno faz a compostagem
minha família já fazia tetra e pra mim é
muito estranho pegar uma casca de banana
ana por exemplo quando vou na casa de
alguém e tetra e colocar no lixo comum
né pra mim chega a tremedeira assim não
consiga eu já cheguei por casca de
banana no bolso todo o mercado
eu jogar em casa na composteira para
impor no lixo comum
é uma coisa que para mim se consolidou
como um hábito a mesma coisa para
recicláveis quentes e para a muitos anos
e mesmo com a cooperativa hoje não
passando lá por dificuldades na relação
do poder público a gente continua
separando
então a gente acredita muito nesse poder
do hábito e tem muitos exemplos de
sucesso por aí gerando impactos
positivos
um deles muito emblemático a revolução
dos baldinhos em florianópolis onde
centenas de famílias da comunidade chico
mendes são impactadas positivamente a
partir de geração de emprego renda e
cidadania e eles vendem o composto
produzido em destacado para a
agricultura e é revertido para ações no
bairro
nós temos o composto em são paulo que é
um projecto que distribuiu 2000
minhocários domésticos na capital para
famílias começarem a praticar a
compostagem nas suas casas também é
muito interessante
a tim são carlos o projeto giro da
veracidade gestão integrada de resíduos
orgânicos que visa popularizar a prática
da compostagem através de cursos
oficinas e do aproveitamento de terrenos
de espaços ociosos que transforma em
patins de compostagem comunitária e
hortas né
aqui em são carlos neco nosso projeto
gira a gente tem tentado estabelecer
isso como uma política pública é mais
difícil é porque tem esse interesse que
a gente já colocou os agentes públicos
etc são carlos não tem nenhum plano
municipal de gestão integrada de
resíduos o pm gers que faz parte da
política nacional lei 12.305 ou seja é
algo rudimentar que uma cidade como são
carlos deveria ter e é nós lançamos uma
consulta pública em 2014
conversando com a população través da
câmara municipal perguntando quem era
favorável à prática da compostagem como
política pública e o resultado é muito
emblemático né
qualquer pessoa que entenda minimamente
o que está em jogo é é é favorável a
isso que é algo óbvio é uma obviedade
então
no quase 99% nunca vi uma unidade dessa
né
as pessoas que responderam foram
favoráveis né essa é a consulta pública
está disponível no site da câmara
municipal para baixar as respostas todas
qualitativas detalhadas né
e pra finalizar pra gente é pelo que a
gente entendeu até aqui nós temos várias
condições positivas para fazer isso
acontecer a gente sabe fazer e tem
condições climáticas têm espaço mas tem
dois fatores aí que tal meio complexos
um deles é o tal do incentivo do poder
público que pensa tudo menos no público
em geral - do bem comum então a gente
precisa cobrar para que eles de fato
pensa no bem comum e não haja em nome de
interesses e benefícios próprios
e o segundo é a gente sair um pouco da
nossa zona de conforto e mudar uma
coisinha superbásica banal que ao invés
de ter um lixo de um saquinho de lixo t3
em casa e separar em três categorias na
que eu falei que são quais orgânicos a
vez de novo em jeito bem fácil né gente
então queria pedir de novo pra vocês
separem seu lixo
muito obrigado vamos juntos
[Aplausos]